how's it going reject nation I'm Greg
Alva I'm John Humphrey so when I saw
this dropped I was like oh we already
covered this and I realized it's not
that see on Sunday they premiered a five
minute exclusive clip of before Game of
Thrones for Godzilla king of the
monsters we shot a reaction to it
they're like alright let's just wait for
this to go online officially and then
we'll upload it it hasn't gone online
yet so it's just sitting it's on our
patreon page speaking of which utter
patreon we do weekly q and A's as well
as TV show reaction stream along for
many shows that includes attack on Titan
one punch man my hero academia Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood Gotham John
did all of hunting Hill House and
supernatural and several of those shows
have reaction highlights included those
are one punch man my hero academia
supernatural Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and of course we are
covering Game of Thrones those reaction
highlights are going up on YouTube but
the stream alongs are all on our patreon
page you watch our Gemini man trailer
reaction because that just went up a
little bit ago Wow
these 17 we're gonna see
I heard 1015 yeah
that is what the king
oh they already humor right there Oh No
hey get to touch him this time the
humans need to be essential yeah we got
a we got a backup gun
Wow Wow dude that King Ghidorah versus
Godzilla fight is going on baby
I guess my one concern that I I pick up
from this trailer especially this one in
particular are the human characters
other than Vera Farmiga and Amelia Brown
are they gonna be interesting or feel
necessary to the plot of the movie
because he's always a question you got
this wide range of characters and even
there's something about Kyle Chandler
saying now is our time to get involved
in the fight or whatever they made me go
are you guys gonna feel like completely
what degree of damage or our bums and
you know gun ships and stuff going to
really do to these quote tight yeah it
looks like it has no effect but that's
just my one concern I do think Bradley
Whitford looks really funny he's doing
that what Bradley would retired to do
all the other stuff that were mainly
showing up for you know Rodin King
Ghidorah godzilla mothra and a pair of
monsters because i heard you're gonna
see about ten to fifteen and they said
there's seventeen here so maybe we don't
see all of them maybe there's some
post-credits thing in here that's gonna
set up for when he's gonna fight King
Kong cuz that supposed to be the next
film on this little universe they have
established sure and I'm a little bit
you know establish here this film does
look beautiful in a lot of ways as I
remember the first Godzilla that movie
not like the way way back one that's the
one that came out a few years ago that
one felt like a horror movie
this one feels like a monster epic film
but also if they're staying and tuning
keeping a consistency with having this
sense of wonder with some but not all of
them are just terrifying monsters it
seems like Rodin Ghidorah are terrifying
monster especially at a chioce doesn't
clip like the King Ghidorah moment was
just so scary and Mothra seems to have
that beautiful elegant quality and
Godzilla I think we're supposed to
both for him here you know he's like our
hero but he's also kind of scary and
everyone's like yeah we love this guy
you know yeah I mean that's something
I've gotten from both of these this
final trailer as well as the HBO
exclusive look is just they're kind of
playing up that beauty and Wonder and
Majesty which is an element of movies
that I do appreciate them bringing in
here I remember them having a flavor of
that I spiritually just enjoy that
they're translating that I mean the main
flavor otherwise that I get yeah is
monster mayhem total destruction
I am excited for that and yeah I kind of
share your concern about like what are
the human characters impact going to be
because I know they've got you know a
very grabby cast now I just hope that
there is actually something worthwhile
for them to do you know cuz like Milly
Bobby Brown for example gets a lot of
the same kind of moment across a lot of
these trailers where she's just kind of
looking at something and she screams in
this one sure yeah she's always kind of
just reacting to lacroix big monster
which makes a lot of sense I just you
know I want to get a flavor for their
personalities I feel like she's gonna be
a more special kind of character rather
than just little girls because I think
Kyle Chandler a bear for Megha I think
they are they used to be married or
something like that you know I noticed
in the HBO trailer especially that she
that they holds a photo and there's a
boy in the photo with them the vibe I'm
picking up on is maybe they lost the Sun
and then they fell apart and now they're
gonna you know awaken sometimes because
they let because we see that in that HBO
clip that Vera Farmiga is the one who
like detonates the ice that Ghidorah is
trapped in that's what confused that
like why because it seems like the way
the marketing has been pretty consistent
these monsters are breaking out we need
Godzilla
let's somehow get Godzilla involved in
the fight but then the other trailer it
was good Dora's being released from the
ice due to its like whatsoever why are
they doing that what exactly is
happening is this have to do with that
environmental type of character that
I've heard or we do it's not a cleanse
of the earth you know like I don't know
what's going on exactly
yeah well and that's the thing is this
trailer made it seem overtly clear that
Ghidorah at least by the humor
perspective is the one to beat is the
one to defeat it that really to me
confuses me as to why they would ever
second or a free especially if they're
like we need to maybe partner up or see
if Godzilla will in some way fight on
our behalf and I do wonder if I know the
first movie had at least an ecological
subtext at least acknowledged in it I
hope they bring that back in some way
and I do wonder what it's going to be
because I guess in some way I can see
sort of us set it free and and restore
the balance of what the earth is
supposed to be or something like that
we've seen a lot of that plotline lately
from different movies so I hope it's
maybe a little something more original I
think also Miley Bobby Brown is gonna I
feel that there's a very specific reason
why they hire her as popular in the
stranger thinks okay John you could be
cynical and sarcastic all you want but I
also think that with the way she's
interacting and responding like the kind
of smiles that she has here when she's
touching some of the Titans I think
she's gonna have some type of special
bond or communication ability with like
Mothra Godzilla in some ways she's
singularly prominently featured there's
elements here in the trailers where
she's by herself quite a bit yeah you
know like she's not just like little
girl with her mom she's by herself doing
a lot of things so I feel like there's
gonna be some type of sci-fi connection
that she has to some capacity yeah and
that's not because she's some stranger
things
I mean he's you know all this guy does
is like Marvel that's right yeah such a
DC but even in the old Godzilla movies I
mean I do remember there being certain
elements with kids and you know
connections and whatnot so it's are
those twins that had a connection yeah
yeah it's not without the realm for sure
I just hope that they make the most of
her talent basically here this is the
most in all the Godzilla sure who talked
about the humans the HBO ever just lie
all that's all monsters yeah do
and yeah I mean I ain't shown uh from
the humans I'm showing up for some
monster may have epicness you know it's
like the emotional context of the humans
will of course make it that much more
engaging if that is well done they do a
good job but I think that even if that's
like I think if the monster Mayhem's
great and it's so obviously going to be
like the city I love the way they've
been using whether to you know make the
visual effects of the monster stand out
more a lot of blue rain the weather a
lot of it's like reflective of who the
monster is I like what the wooden
therefore showing shots of Rodin and
Mothra going up against each other it's
really read everywhere yeah well there's
really hellish images to it of such a
prominent shot of Ghidorah rearing up in
front of a cross yeah and you're just
like the gods cannot help you now these
gods will take us on so we should get
something nice to get that IMAX
experience keep a lookout for Aaron came
for you tomorrow have been everyone's
there right now a special press beauty
before we wrap this video up oh let's
give a page of the day shots to a man
named Scuba Steve Scuba Steve you can go
check out his Instagram page does
wonderful graffiti art highly illegal
I'm hoping to get him arrested as soon
as possible but hopefully his card still
stays on file and is not able to cancel
his pledge to his patreon to our patreon
that way he could be in jail were
reaping the profits off of it but he's
also a big horror enthusiast and I
haven't heard from this guy in a few
months and lately I've been giving
shoutouts to people who used to message
me all the time how am I supposed to
keep updating your shoutouts and keep
making it something special in grant if
you're not messaging me back give some
to work with man
dammit skoobs skoobs may oh man Scoob
all right follow him visit him in prison
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell see you guys soon hey
guys I'm very turn